[Music]
he looked me dead in my eyes and tell me
he was going to go sleep with that girl
why do you stay married to him no matter
what he says you think he's lying to you
he's cheated on you before why are you
in this marriage your life will be
misery and it will be hell until you
100% tell the
[Music]
truth hey good morning good afternoon
good night this is John with the Dr John
deloney show show about your mental
health your marriage your emotional
health trying to find some light in a
world just gone mad it's the New Year
hope your New Year's off to a great
start hope you've implemented some new
habits you are reverse engineering the
way you want your home to feel you and
the people that you love are
reconnecting I hope that you're hanging
in there hope that you're doing not only
hanging in there I hope you are ahead of
the curve and you're stay stand ahead of
the curve not with big dramatic firework
shows but little tiny
WIS eating a little bit better choosing
to exercise choosing to have hard
conversations instead of stomping around
your house or imagining that you can
change somebody else's Behavior by
nagging or ignoring or being drama
whatever is going on in your life I hope
that you are making the changes you
promised yourself you're going to make
and if you're struggling you're already
falling off it's not too late to get
back on every day is a new day you can
start start over if you want to be on
the show this show is real people going
through real stuff give me a buzz at
1844 693
3291 or go to John dooney.com
askas let's go out okay we got a couple
on the line these are some of my
favorite and so we're going to go out to
this is spart
Tennessee uh let's open up to Jesse what
up Jesse what's going on Dr John we're
just making it happen dude all right and
so I'm gonna bring your uh wife on is
that right yeah all right hang on one
second I'm gonna bring on
Haley all right Haley Haley why you bug
are you on yes how out to John all right
so I got Jesse and Haley here from
Sparta Tennessee all right so uh who
wants to go
first uh I'll go first okay who's in the
most trouble here how about that
uh that would be me I'm the one that's
always causing the trouble all right
let's start with you go for it all right
well we've been in kind of a tough spot
for quite a while now and every time we
have difficult conversations about
something that I've done um I always
tend to distance myself from whatever
the situation may be or try to minimize
my involvement my question is how do I
fully open up my wife
and not be dishonest with her during
those difficult conversations tell the
truth am I am I over am I
oversimplifying it no no you're not it's
I've always I've always done that like
tried to distance myself from I guess
what I've done like tried to minimize my
involvement and not I don't know I don't
know how to stop
it I mean normally half the battle
that's not true two-thirds of the battle
is helping somebody recognize that
they've got something they need to do
differently new actions they need to
take you know that yeah so give me an
example of something or there's
something must have happened for yall to
call what happened recently that you're
that you're trying to minimize your
distance yourself from and you don't
want to do that anymore well um like at
work I started a new job here recently
and uh
there was this cooworker of mine it was
a female and we started talking and it
wasn't nothing out of the ordinary just
two co-workers talking but then we
started flirting and and that's as far
as it went and that's as far as I I
would allow it to go and I told her you
know twice that I was married but I
tried to my wife asked me several times
about it and I kept telling her that
nothing was going on I wasn't doing
anything I hadn't done anything wrong
but I knew that it was wrong just to
even be communicating with her flirting
with her so let's let's let's hone in on
the word
flirt um there's been people in my life
when I've been married over 21 years
that I'd say that's just kind of I
especially in the old days like that was
kind of my
energy but it was no text messages there
so people use the word flirt and it's
just
like being extra ra um connected if you
will then some people say no we were
just flirting and you were
sending um nude pics back and forth to
each other so be very specific Describe
the word flirt to me uh just you know
laughing and caring on we never we never
sent lty text or anything back and forth
never phone calls nothing like that it
was just you know we were talking and we
laugh at each other's jokes or whatever
and just I don't
know I don't understand what the problem
is like I laugh at Kelly's jokes all the
time I don't flirting but I laugh at her
jokes all the time she does not laugh at
my jokes because most of my jokes are
directed at her right but but I don't
understand the what's the
problem she says that I had an emotional
affair on her even though I never I
never said anything about her or to to
her about my wife or anything that was
going on between us or nothing like that
and it never went any further than just
conversations Haley what am I missing
here well for one thing uh he started
acting really different to
me and like not wanting to have much to
do with me and he looked me dead in my
eyes and told me he was going to go to
sleep with that girl three different
times
hold on hold on hold on hold on haly
hold on Jesse you kind of left that part
out did you look your wife in the eye
and say you're going to go sleep with
somebody else never directly no yes inde
did
I I mean I in so many words yes I did I
told her if she didn't shut up then I
was going to do that which I probably
shouldn't have I'd say that's a lot of
this problem
here why did you tell your wife to shut
up or you going to go hook up with a
cooworker
because at that time nothing was going
on and she just kept on and kept on and
we do not have grownup adult
conversations it's always screaming and
yelling and accusing and most of the
time it's just
accusing so before I go back to Haley
Jesse is there here's the deal this is
as honest as I can
be there are couples like you and Haley
yeah
where there is a woman in this
relationship always always
always picking threatening pointing out
what about this I can't believe you did
that and the guy in the in the
relationship is always like feels like
they're tap dancing in velvet shoes on
on thin
ice yeah EX
there's also idiotic
husbands
who cheat on their wives and then five
years later get mad that they still and
still flirt with co-workers and talk
about co-workers
and are looking at pornography when
they're supposed to be in the other room
having dinner and I could just the the
the don't call and they're late 5 hours
going I could just make an entire list
here and so you leave a wife strug Ling
and grasping for straws and creating
stories to backfill
horrific bad husband Behavior I say bad
husband that sounds like a child but
very childish husband
Behavior well say I'm I'm always home as
soon as I get off work I tell her I'm
headed home I come straight home from
work and I'm I'm with her every time I'm
not at work I'm with her okay Haley what
am I missing here I mean it's starting
to feel more and more like a like Jerry
Springer like what like tell me what am
I missing is he's been lying to me and
he downplays things for like seven years
there's been a lot of Deceit there's
been a lot of stuff he's done give me
some examples give me some examples ask
him what about what give me some
examples um well he had shudio on me
like years ago eight years ago I think
um and then um we are both recovered
addicts okay but um there was one time
he was using behind my back for seven
months okay and was lying to me and it
it just got drug out and every time he
does something he never gives me
time to heal from that before he does
something
else
and how do haly how do you Haley how do
you heal from
things
it's just really T I guess and I try to
trust him but he's always deceiving me
and manipulating me and tells me I'm
crazy like the thing at work he went up
there and told all his co-workers that I
was just making that stuff up that he
didn't do
anything and I I believe them I just
really believe there's more to it than
what he's letting
on because he's my husband and I know
him
okay and he's just so
distant and I just feel like he's more
invested in that girl than he will let
on because I asked him two two months
ago to get transferred he
refused
um it's just everything I asked him to
do to help me in this marriage just like
he'll do it for a couple of days and
then it's just me like holding
everything together by
myself so here's here's the truth of the
of the situation Haley as quickly as I
can get to
it either your um radar
system is wildly over poignant it's
wildly over sensitive to
stimuli and every single thing this poor
man does your body reacts as though you
know the truth he's doing this he's
lying about this he's using this he's
cheating on me over here that could be
either
that or
Jesse you called my show and you can lie
in your house dude but you can't call
this show and disrespect me and all the
people who Tune In by not telling the
truth oh I know that and you're slowly
drown in your water and I drown in your
wife and gaslighting your wife to
death so I'll ask you just point blank
if we're going to do this let's do it
are you honest and nothing happened
between you and this woman at work zero
things I swear to you zero things
happened okay zero what is it about your
interactions with
her and your relationship with your wife
that is setting every setting your
wife's
emotional senses on
fire I guess it's because we've been so
distant from each other for the past I
don't know so
long and then every time something
happens it's like she's either accusing
me of something or I'm lying about this
or I'm lying about that and a lot of the
times it's it has nothing to do with
anything why do you lie to her then is
it e let me ask you this is it easier to
lie to her on little things because you
don't want to get poked and prodded and
pulled apart and threatened and all that
well see the thing is is that most of
the time I tell her the truth most of
the time it's just these these big
things I try to minimize my involvement
in but I guess I told her it's no want I
don't want to hurt her feelings but I
know that's not
it I I guess it's just cuz I don't want
to let her down or I don't want her to
be right about me I
guess because she always accuses me of
like doing stuff on my phone and and
none of it's been true and we'll sit
down and go through everything and she
still believes what she thinks even
after we talk about everything Haley is
that
right there will be like history on his
phone like all these texting apps and
video apps and chatting apps and Skype
and all that started when he started
talking to that girl but he still denies
it but there's history on his phone he
lied to me about even being around that
girl for the longest this is been going
on for months and two weeks ago is when
he admitted that he had other intentions
with her after looking me in my eyes and
saying all that
stuff
and I just I don't know I just feel like
there's more to it he says there's not
but he'll drag it out for years before
he'll tell me the truth about one little
thing he does have a problem with porn
always
has and he lies about that for years and
then he'll finally be like oh yeah this
time but WHYY why stay married to him
you can't sleep you don't trust him as
far as you can I mean you can't you
don't trust him the moment he walks into
the next bedroom much less out the front
door and listen No Matter listen no
matter what he
says you think he's lying to you you
think he's cheating on you you think he
might be using again you think he's
deceiving deceiving
you he's cheated on you before why are
you in this
marriage I love him and we have a family
together we've been together for 13
years and I just I know he's a better
person but he just
refuses to to give me what I need and
I'm gave seven years
and I don't know he keeps giving me
false promises but all his actions say
different than his words
so Jesse I'm just going to ask you one
more time and then I'll I'll wrap this
call up and give you all a little what
little Direction I can possibly give
you okay you called me and said you
minimize things that's a sophisticated
way of seeing you lie about things to
make yourself less of a culprit in a
situation
yeah this whole call you said you don't
lie you always tell the truth you always
come home nothing ever happens no no I
lie to her I do lie to her but whenever
it I lied to her only about like certain
things things that I actually have done
I lied to her about name them give me a
couple well like um the porn thing I
lied to her about that okay what else
what else talking talking to that girl I
about that what
else um how long have you got keep going
rattle them
off
um I that's just two of the the biggest
things that I can keep going now you're
doing what you called me and asked me
about you distancing yourself from it go
say
it I'm looking at other women I lied to
her about that for years okay keep
going that's seriously all I can think
of it's not there's more keep going I'm
sure there is more I just why do you
have a whole bunch of video chatting um
apps on your phone I don't I do not and
she just invin it
pH no it says whenever you go on my
history it says um something download
whatever that video app is called but I
have never used it never I've never used
a texting app I've never used a video
chatting app I've never used any of that
stuff and she can go through all the
apps that have ever been on my phone
because they're still there you just
happen to to download them and you just
like held on they've never been
downloaded that's what I'm saying
they've never been downloaded all right
well here here here's the deal here's
the
deal Haley this is just dude I've talked
to y'all for for I don't know 10 minutes
Haley I think that there's been a World
created
both by both of
y'all where you are unable to walk with
any sort of certainty on the foundation
that is in your that is your home that
is your marriage that is your
relationship
period Jesse if you are
completely 100% innocent here which
there's not one cell in my body that
believes that but if you
are lying for years about using about an
a an affair about pornography about
talking to other women about looking
other women telling your wife to shut up
or you're going to go sleep with a lady
at
work etc etc
etc you've created a con context in your
home you've created you've pumped air
into your home that makes it impossible
for your wife to
breathe and Haley if he's not doing all
these things and you are just have a
pair of glasses on that is constantly
looking for a reason why you've got to
get worked up about something you're
going to find it you're going to imagine
it whether it's on his phone or not
here's what I have to
say this will be the rest of your life
and unless yall decide to do something
different together Jesse your life will
be misery and it will be hell until you
100% tell the truth and I'm telling you
I don't think you're telling the
truth that's just me Haley you will
never have peace in your home and your
marriage until a Jesse tells the truth B
you decide to forgive and C you all
decide to build something new together
end of story
period but if you choose to stay in a
marriage and 100% of your day is looking
for places where he may or may not or
I'm just confident I know it where he's
doing things to hurt you and hurt your
marriage what do you why why would you
do that why would you live that
life and Jesse why would you stay
married if you're with somebody who
thinks so little of you and thinks you
are lying to them all the time 24/7 365
all the time and you're just this
innocent guy trying to make a living
trying to do good work yeah you flirt at
work wow
but you don't do anything wrong
ever why would you stay in this
marriage there will be no peace in your
home Jesse and Haley until you'll both
decide to tell the
truth there will be no peace in your
home Jesse and Haley until youall
decide once all the truth is on the
table I'm going delete everything from
my phone period if it means that much to
you I will not go back I will get
transferred to the next town over and I
will not go to that place but when I do
this you can't keep you cannot keep
hassling me about things that are not
happening I will never minimize
something that I do wrong and I'll never
yell and call you stupid and tell you to
shut up woman and I'm sleeping with
other women I'm never going to talk to
you like that cuz nobody deserves to be
talked like that and I'm not going to
screw rze every little tiny Breath You
Take to see if you're doing this and
cheating this and line I'm going to
stop cuz peace is worth more than
that I can't recommend this enough y'all
got to stop what you're doing just stop
both of you and decide to go see
somebody a counselor in your local
commun there and spart please do that
please do
that that's as far as I can go on this
call
guys there's some y that needs to happen
in your home there's some forgiveness
that needs to happen in your home and
there's a radical control alt delete
that needs to happen with how you talk
to each other and how you plan for what
happens tomorrow we'll be right
back I'm so excited that eight sleep is
partnering with the Dr John deloney show
to take care of our listeners you and
help you change your marriage and change
your life our friends at ate sleep have
created a fitted sheet with cooling and
heating technology embedded inside
called the eight sleep pod the the Pod
cover can easily be added to your
existing mattress like a fitted sheet
for individualized temperature
adjustments down to 55° where normal
people sleep all the way up to
110° based on your environment and body
temperature throughout the night it
cools down or warms up each side of your
bed and over time it learns what your
body needs and it does it automatically
and in turn it improves Your Sleep
Quality like you have to experience to
believe it the eight sleep po also has
built-in vibration alarms that wake you
up when it's time and it gradually
changes the temperature of your mattress
cover to gently wake you up it can even
provide you sleep and health reports for
each side of the bed including sleep
stages sleep time heart rate HRV and you
don't have to wear anything eight sleep
is the ultimate sleep experience and
it's proven to give you up to 34% more
deep sleep per night and you can stay
married doing it you owe it to yourself
and your marriage to to at least check
out eight8 sleep and learn more go to
8sleep.com to read more learn more and
see if you want to change your sleep and
show up better in your life that's EIG
ght sleep.com dealone or enter promo
code delone at checkout for up to $400
in savings off an eight sleep bundle go
check it
out all right let's go out to Baltimore
and talk to Denise what's up Denise
hi Dr deloney how are you I'm I I don't
know after that last call I'm still
trying to figure out what day it is so
how are you I'm doing okay thank you for
taking my call it's such an honor to
talk to you I'm a big fan of you and the
the whole Ramsey team and I really
respect the the advice and the truth
that I hear you delve out to others just
like on that last call
so talk to you I don't know how much I
helped on that last call but so what's
up what's up
so I really reached out because I'm
looking for some help in um dealing with
something see my husband and I he
recently had a DUI incident hey do me a
favor talk directly into your phone for
me oh can you hear me better now I'm
sorry yeah that's much better all right
um so yeah he recently had a DUI
incident okay he had been drinking with
friends and got involved in in an
accident where no one was hurt but he
did hit another parked car um and just
was not a not a good situation and his
drinking in general and drinking and
driving has been kind of a you know an
ongoing issue for I would say the past
at least probably three to five years or
more um but his luck just kind of
finally ran out and it kind of came to a
head when this happened and we've had
you know lots of arguments and discuss
discussions where I tried to stress to
him that if he didn't make some serious
changes there were going to be some
consequences to his actions and that's
what has happened so um there's a chance
he could go to jail I know there's
probably going to be some significant
fines and legal fees and other things
that are going to be a burden to us
and I just I'm struggling with how to
deal with it um he is very
ashamed um and regrets the whole thing
um I think that it has been a wakeup
call for him he says he's completely
done with drinking allog together
doesn't want any alcohol at all um but
I'm just really do you
believe I I want to I don't think you I
don't think you would be calling me if
you believed him yeah just because you
know it nothing like this has ever
happened before
um you know this serious but he has
absolutely said that before that he you
know he can he doesn't have a problem he
can manage it himself um but yeah he I I
don't know how to to trust him and
believe that he really does want to stop
drinking so here's the thing the DUI if
he quits drinking and cleans himself up
be the luckiest thing that ever happened
to him nobody got hurt it's going to
cost them a you you think you know how
expensive this is going to be it will
be it will be astounding how expensive
this is okay and good good I'm glad it
is it should be more expensive I got I
got zero none zero sympathy for people
who get D DUIs period zero ever ever um
but it comes with it right he he mouthed
off to a bullying up punch in the nose
that's what happens right so that's not
why why you're
calling you're calling because you're
married to somebody who has heard you
speak your
heart and has said I don't
care I don't care how you feel I don't
care what you want I don't care what you
need I'm just gonna do my thing that's
the issue
here the a secondary component is those
things could kill somebody else and it
could have he just hit a parked car like
an
idiot yeah right yep and so what you
have to deal with the DUI is the DUI man
he got he's going to get arrested have
to go into the legal system he's going
to have to report that on every job he
ever has unless he gets an attorney that
pleads it down for him it's going to
cost him a unfathomable out of money um
that y'all probably don't have that
that's all part of the consequences but
even the way you say that to him you
sound like a mom talking to a little
boy not a wife because here's what a
wife says a mom says if you keep doing
that there's going to be be
consequences a wife says I think
enough about I I have respect and
dignity for myself
enough that if you put yourself or me or
other innocent people in this
position right I'm
out yeah here's the quote unquote in
counseling we call the or what you can't
put up a
boundary or hold somebody account
accountable without an or what statement
you got to quit drinking or what well no
I mean not really anything I'm just
going to like nag you or you got to quit
drinking and driving okay or what like
uh I'm I don't know
like so I'll ask you what's your or what
statement because here and here's why
that's important I want you to think
through it if there's no or what
statement what you're saying to yourself
is I've made peace that this is my
life and if that's what you've made
peace with then that's what you've made
peace
with otherwise no it's not are you done
I mean tell me what your or what
statement is no well we've we have had
that discussion since this incident
happened and and what I said to him and
I actually even said it not too long
before um but I told him if you know he
continues down this path of putting
himself and other people at risk I can't
continue to live that way I can't
continue to live with somebody I can't
trust um and that doesn't have like you
said doesn't have any respect and value
you know our lives and what we've built
together and is just willing to throw it
all away because he wants to drink I
just can't so the the one and I'm super
proud of you for saying that that's hard
right that's hard especially if he's
truly not just being a moronic bro but
he's struggling with alcohol there's
things in his life that his body has
said hey Guy this is the best way we
need to uh we can get through a day for
right
now that he is drowning in his own life
and alcohol is his Lifeline like man I
got a lot of uh sympathy for I got a lot
of broken heart for that dude if that's
if that's what's truly happening or if
he's just like a reckless idiot and he's
like yeah bro like then man we got
that's other problem but I'm proud of
you for saying that here's the one
caveat that you have to add this time
you left it very very
vague if you keep putting other people
at risk and having the see what I'm
saying and that leaves to a judgment
call especially a judgment call after a
dude's had four doubles and a couple of
beers I'm not putting anybody at risk
I'm gonna be fine so where your or what
statement has to get clear it has to get
very
specific right if you have a single
drink and get behind the wheel of a car
again I'm filing for divorce are we
clear you're just going to leave me like
that no no no it has nothing to do with
that I've repeatedly told you what I
need from you and you've repeatedly said
those dudes These Bars this drink is
more important than you behavior is a
language right I don't think I've said
it that clearly to him but I have said I
would rather be alone than be in this
situation and again I'd rather be alone
is super it's hard to say but it's very
vague yeah yeah I will you will be moved
out of our
home right right I mean that's the kind
of
clarity otherwise it's G to always be
this amorphic kind of moving in you know
okay yeah and that's kind of what it's
become until Wham he hit somebody thank
God there was nobody in the
car yeah it's hard to hear and it will
be hard to say but I will I don't after
23 years of being married I don't want
to to see that come to an end
but can I say something SC kind of
scary yeah it's not
you this is the the not by your hand but
in your lap of course you don't want it
to end and if you sent papers to him
today that would not be you ending them
marriage he will have made a bunch of
choices he will have slammed the door in
your
face and you will be choosing to turn
around and go the other
way it's not you slamming the door on
him and that's how he'll paint it that's
how his attorney will paint it that's
how all his friends will paint it he
will have slammed the door in your face
and you will have chosen for the first
time in 23 years not just to stand there
on the porch knocking and see if he'll
open it
again right and I think that's some of
the emotion that I'm dealing with
because I have some you know some guilt
around could I have pushed him harder
and you know laid out an ultimatum like
you're saying or you know no Denise this
is hard man this is
hard and when the good times are good
they're really good aren't
they yes and you love this guy right yes
I love him with all my heart right and
part of you thinks if I'm not here to
help he's going to go so far off the
deep and we're all going to lose him
right yes I totally get that and the
scariest part for you is you can't make
him do
anything right he has to decide my worth
my life is worth more than than what I'm
what I'm what I'm living right
now
right and he can announce to the world
I'm done I'm done I'm done unless he's
in a treatment plan unless he's at a
12ep meeting I don't I don't trust that
sentence as far as I can throw it unless
he's not seeing seeing a professional
counselor I don't trust that as far as I
can see
it that's just I've just worked with
people struggling with addiction my
whole
career right and he is you know going
down that path he's um of course I was
recommended by the attorney we talked to
is you know starting treatment he has an
appointment coming up later this week um
is going to be in an ongoing treatment
program um so that's a positive so well
here's what here's where I think your
Clarity needs to to come into I can't
I'm going to give you some some example
prompts but this is not me telling you
what to do okay right I don't want to
confuse the two you've got to
decide but based on what you're telling
me I would have a conversation today or
tomorrow that says hey I haven't been
super
clear and all of this got very clear for
me when you almost died or when you
could have killed somebody so for the
sake of both of us and for me to show
you and prove to you how much I love you
I'm going to be super clear because the
clearer I can be is demonstrative in how
much I love you here's clear if you skip
this meeting you will move out of our
house if you skip your first counseling
meeting and don't continue to go you
will be telling me through your actions
our marriage is
over
yeah because I think in some ways it
would be
unfair for him to skip this meeting and
you to get all mad at him and he would
look at you and go you've always told me
you're I can't do this and you're going
to leave and not going to live like this
but you've never done
anything well now I'm being
clear if you have a single drink and
decide to drive you're telling me I
don't want to be married to you anymore
and I'll react
accordingly Y and you could tell them I
hope to all that is Holy you don't make
that choice that you let me come get you
that you get an Uber that
whatever but I think it feels like it's
all about the DUI and it's going to be
embarrassing you're going to have to
tell your friends it's going to be this
and that it's going to cost a bunch of
money again like I've said that several
times it's not about that it's about a
you almost lost your husband I remember
when I was in a tole of my car on the
way to work um it was about a year and a
half ago now and I was doing whm Hoff
breathing in my car like an absolute
[__] and I total it on the highway here
out here in Nashville my wife got in a
car and drove up here and hugged me she
said I have to I have to see you and I
have to touch you and she saw me in the
parking lot I went out to meet her and
she started weeping in the parking lot
that's you you almost lost him thank God
you
didn't you've been with him a quarter
Century he's a part of you
and you're having to live
with this man has
not decided that his life is worth more
than the way he's living it and that
breaks your heart and that forces you to
make some hard
choices boundaries have to be very very
clear you want to over boundary things
to where you end up having to like
somebody calls your
bluff but I think this is boundary time
this is accountability time this is
direct time and if you choose hey I'm
never going to leave this guy I will
never ever leave him okay then don't put
that on the
table but also don't get don't get
worked up every time he does something
like
this you can be sad that he's that he's
not that he's hurting but you can't be
sad that he did it to you cuz you've
already decided I've accepted this but
it doesn't sound like you're there
anymore sounds like you're
through wondering every every single
night is my husband going to come home
drunk is he going to come home at
all is he going to sit by me on the
couch and be right next to me but not
really be fully there tired I'm tired as
life we both deserve more and if you're
thinking that you're right thanks for
the call Denise wish you guys all the
best we'll be right
back I'm always on the lookout for
supplements food and top-of-the-line
products that enhance your immune system
improve emotional and mental health
vastly improve your digestion and I'm
always looking for ways I can improve my
sleep and Clarity of thought listen I'm
always trying different supplements
Foods powders and potions and recently
without the company knowing I purchased
some of their products with my own money
and I was blown away by the results I
reached out to them and I'm super
excited that organifi is partnering with
me on this podcast to change my life and
yours simply put organifi is Wellness
made easy organifi makes nutrition
delicious for everybody organifi makes
the cleanest products available on the
market and me and my kids personally
take multiple organifi products every
single day my life has changed for the
better from what I think are the best
tasting green powders on the market red
powders that I can mix with water for
caffeine-free energy that doesn't leave
me shaking like a salt shaker gold
powders to help me wind down in sleep
immunity protein magnesium and a special
kids line and more organ takes all the
drama and guesswork out of nutrition
supplements immunity support and
cognitive enhancement and it puts it all
in one place for you and your entire
family you all know I like to experiment
and take lots of different supplements
but if I had to answer the question if I
only had one supplement I could take
what would it be I'd start with organifi
invest in your health in this new year
so you can show up for your spouse your
kids your work and your community we
need you go to organifi.com
backone or use promo code deloney at
checkout for a 20% discount for all the
Dr John deloney show listeners that's
organifi.com
delone all right let's roll out to
Montana and talk to Sweet Sweet Ann
what's up
an hi John deloney what's up how are
you I had chocolate chip cookies and
milk for breakfast so I am fantastic how
are you ah dude I'm kind of jealous
right now I was doing fine until so you
just said that I had eggs and apple and
protein shake like an
idiot man all right so good for you and
so uh we'll prepare for the sugar crash
here in a bit we'll try to get through
this call fast so you can land safely
from your crash what's
up uh I have a question about how do I
set boundaries with friends go for it
what happened great uh so the boundary
is one of my best friends is a guy and I
have a fantastic boyfriend who I really
want to honor and make feel comfortable
and this one relationship and the way we
interact doesn't make him feel
comfortable so some boundaries that we
have set is Luke and I just the the
friend aren't going to hang out
oneon-one anymore hold on we'll go back
I'll edit that part out okay we'll make
a note to edit his name out um so oh
it's a fake name oh it's a fake name
okay cool all right never mind then all
right so Luke all right yep uh so Luke
oh no
uh where was I oh you're just telling me
so you and your boyfriend have made some
boundaries so your boyfriend can feel
comfortable oh yes so Luke and I just
aren't going to hang out one-on-one
anymore and when I interact with him
just a little bit less playful and less
flirty so I've had no problem
implementing these boundaries without
saying a word to Luke and but the thing
is I really don't like that it's making
me feel like a bad friend cuz like I
just kind of casually keep blowing him
off and avoiding him in awkward ways but
every time I try to like practice saying
the words out loud I either feel like a
hypocrite or I
overshare I could use some help
practicing that well I think the deeper
question I have for you is this are
these your rules that you see no this is
healthy and right or are you trying to
make somebody happy this is both of us
this is what we agreed upon that's not
what I asked well played nice try an
well it was a discussion I'll miss his
friendship a little bit but I can also
see how it does come off that
way and so I also like these rules this
seems like the right direction for us to
go something doesn't feel right to
me oh well that's
unfortunate
so
like let's take your conversation with
your current boyfriend off the table
okay one of your best friends in the
world happen to happens to be a guy you
laugh youall go hang out and have coffee
whatever absolutely no sexual chemistry
at all is that what you're
saying uh not on my side and so this is
where it comes in both the boyfriend and
I agree that it would not
be out of the ballpark or totally
abnormal if this friend did have a crush
on me if Luke had a crush on me he would
be like oh yeah no that kind of makes
sense nothing from my side I was single
for years while I knew this man and I
never asked him out a single time I got
nothing did he ask you out nope okay
would he if you just called him tonight
and you're like I I can't believe this
I've missed it you're right under my
nose this whole time I love you what
would he
say probably yes but I guess I don't
know
okay I think that um we can be cruel
when we know somebody has feelings for
us and we kind of play right up against
the line
there and we know that there's like this
weird unspoken tension we know you know
kind of but not really but maybe but not
really okay there's I mean that
definitely is where the oversharing
comes in tell me about oversharing what
do you mean by that oh well like if I
went to set these boundaries the thing
is the one-on-one rule would make me
feel like a hypocrite because like I
would still go hang out with some of my
other guy friends just the two of us
there's no issues there but there would
be issues with Cam because of the fact
that we both see that type of
relationship being a possibility both
the boyfriend and I think that would be
possible so for me to set the clear
boundary of like hey I don't want to
hang out one any on oneon-one
anymore
because we think that our relationship
is too close that feels weird to
overshare like that it feels weird that
you keep having to use a
plural oh I can take the boyfriend out
of it if you would like well it's not
for me I don't I mean I'm gonna sleep
just fine
tonight it it sounds like you kind of
have a crush on this dude and you know
it's not great if you're dating somebody
else am I wrong on that crush on him huh
no Crush nothing okay
so is it just that like full like full
disclosure is it just that your
boyfriend's uncomfortable with him just
gets a bad vibe from that dude oh well
there are friends outside of it he just
thinks that Luke and I have a slightly
flirty
relationship this is so weird I don't I
don't know what to tell you because
here's what I'm trying to paint a
picture
if there's a couple of different buckets
here bucket number one is you don't owe
anybody an exp explanation for any of
your choices you can tell anybody at any
time hey I just
um I'm dating this guy I'm going to quit
going to 101's just me and
you I'm just going to stop okay it just
doesn't feel right and I like you you're
my friend you've been my friend for a
long time I'm just not going to go out
to coffee with you
anymore and then if you have another
person that you work with and you'll go
run grab lunch and he sees it and he's
like wait a minute you said and you
could say now I said to
you you and I have been friends for a
long time we've got a deeper
relationship this whole thing is just
kind of
weird okay see what I'm saying that's
one that works for me number two is if
you're dating somebody and they just get
that gut feeling watch out for that
dude I've learned to honor that I used
to be like whatever uh-uh that's not
real I've learned to honor
that three is like the third vertical
here
is maybe it's time if you and this guy
are getting serious maybe it's time to
say I'm just going to quit going to have
lunches or going to have drinks with
just dudes just me and
them just kind of as a way of being I'm
going to honor you I'm going to honor
our
relationship I'm going to take all the
confusion out of all of
this okay the only place I get stuck
with that one is I go hiking with guys
and I don't want to be eating by a
grizzly bear but outside of that I could
honor and respect that I like the way
that works I would hope you don't get
eaten by a grizzly bear yes remember the
rule of hiking in Grizzlies you don't
have to outrun the grizzly you just have
to outrun the slowest other person
there well that's and man I had cookies
for breakfast John deloney I might be
that person but listen like the
uh I don't know an it feels like there's
something else here no I liked what you
said John you hit it on the head I don't
owe an
explanation I just hey these are the
boundaries yeah this is what I'm
choosing to live by I don't have to
explain why it's different for some
people or why relationships end up
different ways no but I
also I don't want you to just move from
one situation to another
either I don't want you draw a boundary
with one guy that you've had a good
relation ship with and then all of a
sudden you you start hiking with these
dud other dudes all the time and then
suddenly they get an idea like oh she's
kind of into us too she calls wants to
hang out a lot now and that turns into
and your boyfriend's in like dude okay
well can you not do that
too I have been looking for lots of
friends it's been a working progress
there you go that's probably
Fair the whole I I I
would
some people have blanket rules I I'm
dating somebody or I'm married to
somebody so I will not have friends of
the opposite
gender I think that's very very hard to
do in the modern world I
also have seen people be very flippant
with that and find themselves in a world
of trouble I would never cheat on on so
and so yeah but they would now we got a
mess
right and sometimes somebody comes into
a relationship ship and y'all are dating
and it's all good but from the outside
it just kind of doesn't feel right it
looks weird it's like hey you're always
going out and having chips and queso
you're always going out and hanging out
you're always going out having a drink
always just makes me feel uncomfortable
and if we're going to date like I want
it just to be us that goes out and does
one-on one cool all right I'll in that
but I'm gonna go hiking with these guys
I'm gonna go do this with these guys and
I'm gonna go do that with those guys
well the whole thing just gets murky I
would challenge you and your current
boyfriend to sit down and say what are
our values who are we going to be but
besid just this guy what are what are
things that make you
uncomfortable what are things that make
you
uncomfortable I would not head off to
the woods to go hiking with just like
three other women while my wife was like
all right you guys have fun I just
wouldn't do that that whole thing L
would not be
great and like it's not weird for Kelly
and I to go have a meeting downstairs in
the cafeteria while she drinks her
Straight Bourbon and I have coffee in
the middle of the work day while she's
getting tattooed none of those things
are true so there's a balance here and
everybody listening is going to have an
opinion and a thought and like oh my
gosh I can't I think it's just coming up
with your own values the one thing I get
nervous about is an overly zealous
overbearing partner who begins to
control your time who you see where you
go what you think is
funny and and I get nervous about that
but not my relationship just set your
boundaries and set your values firm and
um yall go from there we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey it's delone last year I came to
an inflection point I was exercising
regularly I was disciplined in my diet I
was getting regular blood work done and
I was working hard on my marriage I was
doing all the right things but I had not
dealt with old traumas and old stories
that were negatively impacting my
marriage my relationship with my kids my
work and me I'm the expert I teach
others what to do but I was slowly piece
by piece falling apart so I swallowed my
pride and with the encouragement of my
family and friends I reached out to a
therapist and started seeking true deep
healing a year later I'm a radically
different man all for the better and I
know finding a therapist in your local
community can be almost impossible or if
you do find one it's so expensive you
can't afford to go even if you want
wanted to and that's why I love the work
betterhelp is doing in the world
betterhelp is online therapy with real
licensed therapists who are available on
your schedule when you contact better
help you will fill out a short
questionnaire and they will match you
with the licensed therapist plus you can
switch therapist at any time for no
extra charge you've been working so so
hard and now it's time to get to the
root of your pain for permanent
extraordinary life change visit
betterhelp.com dealone toay to get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com
delone all right we're back as we wrap
up today's show man Today's Show is full
of what was it just was it me it just
felt like weird relationship stuff going
on this was a weird one today there was
some ick was a lot of ick
today
h just a lot of ick just a lot of things
that
aren't it was wasn't a lot of answers
there's more there yeah there's lot of
it felt like a lot of like well we
should probably spend an hour together I
see you in person yes yeah and and just
like not clear answerers let me see your
phone ambiguity amb oo that's how fancy
people say ick well done song is by the
great and powerful pink it's called Just
give me a reason right from the start
you're a thief you stole my heart and I
your willing victim I let you see the
parts of me that weren't all that pretty
and with every touch you fix them now
you've been talking in your sleep things
you never say to me tell me that you've
had enough of our
love our love I haven't had enough of
you America I'll see you soon
bye